hello this is Matthew from simply
learned and today we're going to go
through part one of a two part series on
interview questions that you are likely
to be asked if you are interviewing for
a job that focuses on DevOps so there
are approximately seven sections that we
cover in DevOps we go from general
DevOps questions source code management
with tools such as geared at continuous
integration and here we'll focus on
Jenkins continuous testing with tools
such as selenium and then you also have
the operations side of DevOps which is
your configuration management with tools
such as chef puppet intangible continued
ization with dhaka
and then continuous marching with tools
such as Nagios the first video is going
to zero in on the left hand side of the
screen where zero in on those general
DevOps questions source code management
continuous integration then continuous
testing our second video is going to get
into the operations tools and we'll get
into that and the next time you come
back above me there's probably a link
that will take you straight to that
video so let's just get into those
general DevOps questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is dev ops different from agile
and the reality is is that DevOps is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
solutions that's different from agile we
look at the evolution of delivery over
the last five to ten years we've gone
from waterfall and based delivery to
agile delivery which is on Sprint's to
where we are with continuous integration
and continuous delivery around DevOps
the whole concept of DevOps is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any
that come up have to be communicated
effectively and efficiently back to the
dev and ops team another area in which I
see that DevOps is different is really
the response that we have for how we
engage with the customer so the customer
is coming to your website to your mobile
app to your chat bot or any digital
solution that you have and has an
expectation when you're going through
and actually doing a dev ops paradigm
the old model would be that you would
capture requirements from the customer
then you do your development then you do
your testing and there would be these
barriers between each of those as we
move faster through from waterfall to
agile what we saw is that with agile we
were able to respond much faster to
customer demands so instead of being
weeks or months sometimes in some cases
years between releases of software what
we saw it would was a transition to
weeks and months for releases on
software now we see with DevOps is that
the release cycle has shrunk even
further with the goal of continuously
delighting the customer how further has
that release cycle shrunk to there are
companies that have gone from having
releases of once a week or once every
two weeks or once a month to now having
multiple releases a day indeed some
companies have up to 50 releases a day
this isn't something to also bear in
mind is that each of those releases are
tested and verified against test records
so that you can guarantee that the code
that's going to production is going to
be good continuous code so what are the
differences between the different phases
of DevOps so effectively there are two
main phases of DevOps there's the
planning and coding phase and then
there's the deploying phase and you have
a tool such as Jenkins that allows you
to integrate between both environments
some of the core benefits that you may
have to dev ops are going to be some
technical benefits and some business
benefit so if somebody asks you what are
the benefits of DevOps you can reply
that from a technical point of view
you're able to use continuous software
delivery to constantly push out code
that has been tested and very
fight against scripts that have been
written and approved you can be able to
push out smaller chunks of code so that
when you have an issue you're not having
to go through massive blocks of code or
massive projects you go through just
very small microservices or small
sections of code and you're able to
detect and correct problems faster on
the business side the benefits are
absolutely fantastic from a customer
that's coming to your website and or to
your mobile app they're gonna see it
responses happening continuously so that
the customer is always aware that you as
a company are listening to their demands
and responding appropriately you're able
to provide a more stable environment and
you're able to scale that environment to
the demands of the number of customers
that are using your services so how do
you approach a project that needs to
implement DevOps
so this is really an exciting area for
you to be in
so there are effectively three stages
when it comes to actually working in a
DevOps the first stage is an assessment
stage and think of this as the back of
the napkin ideation stage this is where
you are sitting with a business leader
and they're giving you ideas of what
they would like to see from feedback
that they've had from their customers
this is blue sky opportunity this is
thinking of big ideas that second stage
and this often comes as a fast followed
to stage one is actually proving out
that concept so developing a proof of
concept and a proof of concept can
actually be multiple different things so
it could be something as simple as a
wireframe or it could be something that
is as complex as a mini version of the
final application depending on the scope
of the work that you're delivering will
really depend on how complicated you
want the POC to be but with that in mind
whatever choice you make you have to be
able to deliver enough in the POC so
that when you present this to a customer
they're able to respond to that creation
that you've developed and able to give
you feedback to be able to validate that
you are going with the right solution
and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your dev ops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code are based on a backlog of
features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with DevOps what
you're also looking at is putting in
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that's being delivered
so that once you've actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated
where are the failure points and you
want to use that data and feed that back
into your continuous integration and
have that as a means to be able to
backfill the demand of work that gets
completed in the bank flog so what is
the difference between continuous
delivery and continuous deployment so
continuous delivery is based on putting
out code that can be deployed safely to
production it ensures that your
businesses and functions are running as
you would expect them to be so it's
going through and completing the code
that you'd actually see continuous
deployment in contrast is all about
ensuring that you are automating the
deployment of a production environment
so you're able to go through and scale
up your environments to meet the demand
of both the solution and the customer
this makes software development and
release processes much more faster and
more robust so if we look here we can
actually see where continuous
integration and continuous deployment
come hand-in-hand so when you actually
start out with the initial pushes of
your code that's where you're doing your
continuous integration and your
continuous delivery and then at some
point you want to get very comfortable
with deploying the code that you're
creating so it's being pushed out to
your production environments one of the
things that's great about working with
the tools that you
use in a DevOps continuous integration
and continuous delivery model is that
the development tools that you use the
containerization tools the testing tools
should always reflect the production
environment what this means is that when
you actually come to deploying solutions
to production there are no surprises
because your development team have been
working against that exact same
environment all the way through so a
question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of the
configuration management and dev ops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas I'm the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences is
the ability manage and handle large
changes to multiple systems in seconds
rather than days hours or weeks as that
may have happened before
the second area is that you want to also
demonstrate the business reasons for
having configuration management and the
business reason here is that allows IT
and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to merge a significant
number of servers and domains that may
have multiple servers and it allows you
to effectively manage servers that are
deployed on cloud or private cloud and
allow you to do this with high accuracy
so how does continuous monitoring help
and maintain the entire architecture of
the system so when this question comes
up you want to dig in and show your
knowledge on how configuration and
continuous monitoring is able to control
an entire environment so the number one
topic that you want to bring up when it
comes
to continuous monitoring is that worth
being able to effectively monitor your
entire network 24/7 for any changes as
they happen you're able to identify and
report those faults or threats
immediately and respond immediately for
your entire network instead of having to
wait as it happens sometimes for a
customer to email or call you and say
hey your website's down nobody wants
that that's an embarrassing thing the
other three areas that you want to be
able to highlight are the ability to be
able to ensure that the right software
and the right services are running on
the right resources that's your number
one takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for DevOps is Amazon's
Web Services AWS and they have a really
five distinct areas that you can zero in
on board services so when the question
comes up what is the role of AWS in
DevOps and you want to really hold out
your hand and list of five areas of
focus using your thumb and finger so you
want to have flexible services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that AWS and
and other cloud providers but AWS r7t
the leader in this space are great for
being able to provide support for the
role of DevOps so one of the things that
we want to be able to do effectively
when we're releasing any kind of
solution is to be able to measure that
solution and so KPIs are very important
so you will be asked for three important
dev of KPIs and so three that really
come to mind
are very effective the first one is mean
time to failure recovery and what this
talks about is what is the average time
they take to recover from a failure and
if you have experience doing this then
look at the experience you have and use
a specific example where you were able
to demonstrate that mean time to failure
recovery
the second is deployment frequency and
with deployment frequency you want to be
able to discuss how often do you
actually deploy solutions and what
actually happens when you actually do
those deployments and what does the
impact to your network look like when
you're doing those deployments and then
the third one is really tied to that
deployment frequency which is around
what is the percentage of failed
deployments and so how many times did
you deploy to a server and something
happened where the server itself failed
what we're looking for when you're going
through and being asked for these KPIs
is experience with actually doing a
DevOps deployment and being able to
understand what DevOps looks like when
you're pushing out your infrastructure
and then the second is being able to
validate that self auditing ability and
one word of caution is don't go in there
and say that you have a hundred percent
success the reality is that servers do
degrade over time and you maybe want to
talk about a time when a server did
degrade in your environment and use that
as a story for how you were able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
gonna be asked to explain infrastructure
as code and really it's it's something
that actually becomes a byproduct of the
work you have to do when you're actually
putting together your DevOps environment
and infrastructure as code really refers
to the writing of code to actually
manage your environment and you can go
through many of the other tools that
we've covered in this series but you'll
see that XML or Ruby or Yama are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the
physical hardware versus a traditional
model which is having software and
installing our software directly onto
the machine this is really important
when it comes to cloud computing there
really is a strong emphasis of being
able to explain infrastructure as a
service and infrastructure as code is
fundamental to the foundation to
infrastructure as service and then
finally allows you to be able to talk
about how you can use scripted languages
such as Yammer to be able to create a
consistent experience for your entire
network all right so let's now get into
the next section which is source code
management and we're going to focus
specifically on git the reason being is
that get is really the most popular
source code management solution right
now there are other technologies out
there but for the types of distributed
environments that we have a source code
management with git is probably the most
effective so the first question you'll
be asked when it comes to get is to talk
about the difference between centralized
and distributed version control and if
we look at the way that the two are set
older technologies such as older
versions of Team Foundation server
though the current version does that she
have get in it but older versions
required a centralized server for you to
check in a check out of code the
developer in the centralized system does
not have all the files for the
application and if the centralized
server crashes then you actually lose
all of the history of your code now in
contrast a distributed model actually we
do check in our code to a server however
for you to be effective and building out
your solution you actually check out all
of the code for the solution directly on
to your local development machine so you
can actually have a copy of the entire
solution running on your local machine
this allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows for
scalability when it comes to building
out your team so if you have a team and
that may be in
Europe you can see then scale that team
with people from Asia from North America
or South America very easily and not
have to worry about whether or not they
have the right code of the wrong code
and in addition to that if the actual
main server where you're checking in
your code does crash it's not a big deal
because you actually have each person
has a copy of the code so as soon as the
server comes back up you have to check
back in and everybody's running back as
if there was nothing that happened at
all so one of the questions you'll be
asked is to give the answer to some of
the commands you use for working with
git so if you were to be asked the
question is what is the git command that
downloads any repository from github to
your computer on the screen we have four
options we have get push get fork get
clone and get commit the answer in this
instance would be get clone now if you
want to be able to push code from your
local system to github repository using
git then first of all you want to be
able to do is connect the local
prostitute or a remote repository and in
the example you may want to talk about
using the command git remote add origin
and then the actual path to a github
repository you could if you want to
actually at this point also talk about
other repositories such as get lab that
you can also work with or a private git
repository that would be used just for
the development team once you've
actually then added the local repository
into your local computer then the second
action you want to use is a push which
is to actually push your local files out
to the master environment so you use the
command git push origin master so one
question you may be asked is what is the
difference between a bare repository and
a standard way of initializing and git
repository so let's look through what is
a standard way so the standard way using
git init allows you to create a working
directory using the command git init and
then the folder that creates is the
folder that creates all the revision
history related to the work that you're
doing in contrast using the bare way you
have a different commands for setting
that up so it would be get in it - -
bear and it does not contain any working
or checked out source files
locally on your machine in addition the
revision history is actually stored in
the root folder verses a subfolder that
you'd have with the normal git init
initialization so which of the following
CLI commands would you be used to rename
a file so we have guitar em get em v get
RM dash R or none of the above
well in this instance it would be gate
and V a question that you'll be asked
around commit is going to be what is the
process to revert a commit that has
already been pushed and made public and
there are two ways you can address this
the first is to actually address the bad
file in the new commit and you can use
the command git commit dash M and then
put in a comment for why that file is
being removed the second is to actually
create a new commit that actually undoes
all the changes that were made with the
bad commit and then to do that you would
use git revert and then the commit ID
and the commit ID and it could be
something such as five sixty zero nine
three eight F but you'd have to find
that from the the commit that you had
made but that would allow you to revert
any bad files that you had submitted so
there are two ways of being able to get
files from a git repository and you're
gonna be asked to explain the difference
between get fetch and get Paul so get
fetch allows you to fetch and download
only new data from a root new repository
it does not integrate any of the new
data into your working files and it can
be undone at any time if you want to
break out the remote tracking branches
in contrast get pull updates the current
head branch with the latest changes from
the remote server so you get all of the
files and downloaded it downloads new
data and integrates with the current
working files you have on your system
and it tries to merge remote changes
with your local ones so one of the
questions you'll get asked about git is
what is a good stash so as a developer
you'll be working on the current branch
within a solution well what happens if
you
come up with an idea where it's
something that will take a different
amount of time for you to be able to
complete but you don't want to interrupt
the mainline branch so what you got to
do is you can actually create a branch
that allows you to start working on your
own work outside of the mainline branch
and this is called git stash allows you
to be able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline branch so you
once you start talking about branching
and get be prepared to answer and
explain the concept of branching so
essentially what it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the mainline branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating a merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is slightly different
approach this is for projects where you
reach a point in a project where you go
okay we're going to effectively restart
the project at this point in time and we
want to ignore the complete history
that's happened before that and that's
called git rebase and that would allow
you to rewrite the project history by
creating a brand-new mainline branch
that ignores all other previous branches
that have happened before it you can if
you want to very quickly and easily find
out all the files that have been used to
make a particular commit so when Sonja
asks you the question how do you find a
list of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command git diff - tree -
and then the hash that you'd use for the
commit and now would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question that you'll be asked
when you're talking about merging files
is what is a merge conflict and git and
how can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have two or
more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you'd go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a high lines of conflict markers and
you all would be a select which
conflicts and you want to keep on which
you want to merge and which ones you
want to change so it's a step through
how you'd actually resolve a merge
conflict and the first step would be
under github you want to be able to pull
the repository name and then the pull
request around that repository in the
pull request list click the pull request
with a merge conflict and that you'd
like to be able to resolve now pull up a
file that will list out all of the
conflicts for you near the bottom of
that file will be a list of the requests
that need to be resolved and then if you
need to make a decision on which
branches you want to keep or which ones
you want to change that will have to be
something you have to put in
instructions inside of the file you'll
actually see that there are conflict
markers within the instructions which
are going to ask you which files you
want to change which ones you want to
keep them if you have more than one
merge conflict in your file scroll down
to the next set of conflict markers and
repeat steps four and five until you
resolve all of the conflicts you will
want to mark your file as resolve in
github so that the repository knows that
you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then on to the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all of
the conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with command line you want to use a
get bash and so when you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local git repository in
command line by using the CD change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file style guide MD
has a merge conflict in it and as before
with working with github you actually go
through and use a tech service and use
any text editor but as you go through
then edit out what you want to keep them
what you want to manage in your conflict
so you actually have a resolution that's
being created so that you'll be able to
then once you're using the conflict
markers you can actually merge your
files together so that the solution
itself will allow you to incorporate
your commits effectively into the
resolution once you've gone through and
applied your changes groups will then
merge the conflicted commits into a
single commit and able to push that up
to your remote repository alright let's
talk about the next section which is
continuous integration with Jenkins so
the first question you'll be asked about
with Jenkins
is explain a master/slave architecture
of Jenkins so the way that Jenkins is
set up is that the Jenkins master will
pull code from your remote git
repository such as github and we'll
check that repository every time there
is a code commit it will distribute the
workload of that
and the tests that need to be applied to
code to all of the Jenkins slaves and
then on request that jenkem mass M the
slaves will then carry out all the
builds and tests to be able to produce
test reports the next question you'll be
asked is what is a Jenkins file and
simply put a Jenkins file as a text file
that has a definition of the Jenkins
pipeline and is checked into a source
code repository and this really allows
for three distinct things to happen one
it allows for a code review and
iteration of the pipeline it permits an
audit trail for that pipeline and also
provides a single source of truth for
the pipeline which can be viewed and
edited so which of the following
commands runs Jenkins from the command
line is it Java - John Jenkins dope war
Java - Ward Jenkins dot jar Java dot -
JA Jenkins jar Java - war Jenkins dot
wall and the answer is a Java dash jar
Jenkins dot war so when working with
Jenkins you're going to be asked what
are the key concepts and aspects of
working with a Jenkins pipeline and you
want to really hold out your fingers
here and go through four key areas and
that is pipeline node step and stay so
pipeline refers to the use defined model
of a CD continues till every pipeline
node are the machines which is which are
part of that Jenkins environment within
the pipeline step is a single task that
tells Jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks perform through
the entire pipeline then tasks could be
build test and deploy so which of the
following file is used to define
dependency in mavin and do we have a
build XML B palm dat XML C dependency
XML or D version dot XML and the answer
is palm XML working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in Jenkins a long
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as
their domain specific language for
Jenkins and there are one or more note
blocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can see see what the actual script
would look like and the right hand side
shows what the actual declaration for
each section of that script would be the
second type of Jenkins pipeline is a
declarative pipeline and a declarative
pipeline right is simple and a friendly
syntax to define what the pipeline
should look like and then you can
actually at this point use an example to
actually break out how blocks are used
to find the work completed in a
decorative pipeline so how do you create
a copy and backup of Jenkins well to
create a backup prayer we African backup
Jenkins Joe Jenkins home directory and
then create a copy of that directory
it's really as simple as that the
question you'll be asked as well is how
can you copy Jenkins from one server to
another well they're essentially there
are three ways to do that one is you can
move a job from one installation of
Jenkins to another by copying the
corresponding job directory the second
would be to create a copy of an existing
job directory and making a clone of that
job directory but with a different name
and the third is to rename an existing
job by renaming a directory so security
is fundamental to all the work that we
do within DevOps and Jenkins provides
the center core to all the work that
gets completed within a DevOps
environment there are three ways in
which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you are asked about this question of
security within Jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a Jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials B is you can
use a LDAP or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate Jenkins users or C you can
actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as o or which
is a more modern method
or being able to authenticate users
you're going to be asked how to deploy a
custom build of a core plug-in within
Jenkins and essentially the four steps
you want to go through first of all
copying the HPI plug-in file into the
Jenkins home plugins subdirectory you
want to remove the plugins development
directory if there is one you want to
create an empty file called plug-in HPI
dot pinned and once you've completed
these three steps restart Jenkins and
your custom build plug-in should be
available how can you temporarily turn
off Jenkins security if the
administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false
security we've disabled allow you to
make your administrative changes and
will not be re-enabled until the next
time
Jenkins is restarted so what are the
ways in which a build can be scheduled
and run in Jenkins well there are four
ways in which you can identify the way a
build can be scheduled on Ryan Jenkins
the first is when source code management
commits new code into the repository you
can run Jenkins at that point the second
can be the carafe to the completion of
other builds so maybe you have multiple
builds in your project that are
dependent to each other and when so many
other builds have been executed then you
can have Jenkins run
you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrate the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart Jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart
Jenkins manually comes up that you have
the answers and there are two ways in
which you can do it one is you can force
a restart without waiting for bills
complete by using the Jenkins URL that
you have for your environment slash
restart or you can allow all running
bills to complete before restart are
required in which case you would use the
command of the URL Theo Jenkins
environments that safe restart so let's
go into the fourth and final section of
this first video which talks about
continuous testing with selenium so the
first question you will be asked most
likely around selenium are what are the
four different selenium components and
again you will want to hold open your
fingers because there are four distinct
environments you have selenium
integrated development environment or
selenium IDE you have selenium remote
control or selenium RC you have selenium
webdriver and then selenium grid you'll
be asked to explain each of those areas
in more detail but this start off with
by looking at selenium driver what are
the different exceptions in selenium
webdriver so it's useful to remember
that an exception is an event that
occurs during the execution of a program
that disrupts the normal flow of that
programs instructions and so we have
four we have a timeout exception an
element not visible exception no such
element exception and a session not
found exception and each of those if we
step through them are the four different
types of exceptions that can be thrown
up when using the selenium webdriver so
as we evolve into our digital world with
the different types of products that are
available for us to be able to build
solutions onto multiple platforms you
gonna be asked can selenium and other
DevOps tools run in other environments
and so a good question around this is
cancelling tests and application in an
android web browser and the short answer
is absolutely yes it can we have to use
the Android driver for it to be able to
work so you want to be able to talk
about the three different types of
supported test within selenium so
the question comes up what are the
different test types supported by salon
you can answer that and there are three
different types of tests first is a
functional test second is a regression
test and third is a load testing test
the functional test is a kind of black
box testing in which test cases are
based on a specific area or feature
within the software a regression test
helps you find any specific areas that
functional tests or non functional areas
of the code wouldn't be able to detect
the load testing test allows you to
monitor the response of a solution as
you increase the volume of hits in how
you're using the code are put onto it an
additional question you'll be asked is
how can you get a text of a web element
using selenium well the get command is
used to retrieve text of a specific web
element it's important to remember
however that the command does not return
any parameters but just returns a string
value so you want to be able to capture
that string value and discuss about it a
question you'll be asked around selenium
is can you handle keyboard and mouse
actions using selenium and the answer is
yes you can but you have to make sure
that you're using the advanced user
interaction API and the advanced user
interaction API is something that can be
scripted into your tests and it allows
you for capturing methods such as a
click and hold and drag and drop mass
events and then keyboard down or
keyboard up key release events so that
if you want you to capture say the use
of control shift or a specific function
button off the keyboard you'd be able to
capture those off the following four
elements which of these elements is not
a web element method a get text be size
C get tag name D sand keys and it's B
size you're going to be asked to explain
what is the difference for when we use
find element or find elements and so if
we look at find element find element
finds the first element in the current
webpage that matches the specified
located value in contrast find element
finds all the elements on the webpage
that matches the specified value when
using webdriver what are the driver
closed and Driver quit commands and
these are two different methods used to
close a web browser session in selenium
so driver close will close the current
web browser in which your focus is set
and drive a quick closes all the browser
windows and ends the webdriver session
completely the final question that you
are likely to be asked in using selenium
is how can you submit a form using
selenium well in this instance that's
relatively easy the following lines of
code will let you submit a form in
selenium which would be web element l
equals driver dot find element and then
you put in the ID and the element ID and
then L submit open close parenthesis
semicolon that's the end of our first of
two parts of video that covers how you
can actually answer questions in a
DevOps interview please stick around and
we have part two coming out right after
this before we've got a video on the
screen already links to that and the
second video will actually take you
through containerization Ducker
and all the other questions that would
be used for completing a comprehensive
DevOps interview
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here